le principe de la proportionnelle c'est
un nombre de représentants au parlement
qui correspond au nombre de voix
recueillies dans le pays
le principe majoritaire quel principe
opposée ces on donne le siège à celui
qui arrive en tête
le modem il se bat pour un principe
combiner l'efficacité du système
majoritaire en donnant effectivement une
prime à celui qui arrive en tête avec la
justice du système proportionnel
c'est à dire que toutes les sensibilités
sont représentés
ce que nous souhaitons c'est un
équilibre les risques du système actuel
c'est les gilets jaunes des gens qui en
ont assez de ceux d'en haut et qui ne ce
qui ne se reconnaissent pas dans le
parlement et qui donc est ce qu'ils font
mais ils occupent les carrefours et ils
font des manifestations il attaque les
ministères etc la violence et c'est la
rue et ça c'était évidemment si vous
n'avez pas la soupape de la
représentation de tout le monde au
parlement vous avez un risque de
débordement
c'est comme ça qu'on a fait les
révolutions dans un système
proportionnel
vous savez que votre voix va compter
quand votre voix compte
vous avez tendance à vous dérange et je
crois qu'il faut effectivement rétablir
absolument là la démocratie dite
représentative au niveau européen
je trouve que le parlement européens
s'affirment en ce moment et c'est une
très bonne chose
le deuxième niveau c'est le niveau
national il faut que le parlement
français et notamment l'assemblée
nationale retrouve un rôle beaucoup plus
grand et que le gouvernement soit obligé
de travailler avec elle
et troisièmement il faut développer la
décentralisation ça rendrait ses chances
à la démocratie représentative et les
français reprendre goût à un jeu
démocratique
quand ils verraient que ce sont bien
leurs représentants qui décide alors
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont le sentiment que
tout est manipulé par le gouvernement et
par là de l'administration et par les
gens riches